[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory you are now on
the fastest available route to
enlightenment today we're getting right
into the news the local news that is
more specifically we're covering the
scariest local news broadcast that
you've ever seen none other than the
creepy internet darling local 58 never
heard of it well I'm not surprised it's
a relatively underground series here on
YouTube that was recommended to me over
on Twitter matpat GT by the way if you
want to follow and offer Theory
suggestions Wow I am so glad it was
shown to me this is the type of horror
that really sticks with me disturbing
psychological horror that just creeps
under your skin and stays there it's a
series that reminds me a lot of Marble
Hornets if you're familiar with that one
seeing a public service announcement
outright tell people to do their
patriotic duty by offing themselves and
then saying that that message will
repeat until there are none left to read
it even after watching it this many
times I still get goosebumps the long
story short here is that I'm excited to
cover the series 1 because we all need a
break from Disney's domination over the
universe sometimes and - this entire
series totals 20 minutes worth of video
not 20 minutes in episode 20 minutes
total and it's available for free right
here right now on YouTube
so there is no reason why if you haven't
seen it before you shouldn't catch up
with it right now real quick so you know
exactly what I'm talking about as I go
through today's theory in fact I'm
linking to it right here in the top
right hand corner of the screen so go
check it out get creeped out and then
come right back no detours otherwise
YouTube will punish me algorithmically
it's not even joke it's true so please
go watch it but then come back ok you're
ready well too late
at first glance local 58 appears to be a
quirky little local access channel the
type you'd find in any small hometown
around the u.s. until you very quickly
veer off the tracks both literally and
figuratively finding yourself trapped in
a world of disturbed dashcams really
aggressive weather alerts and self-help
videos that seemed more like a cults
brainwashing manual and the best part is
it's just getting started
local 58 looks like it'll have plenty
more broadcasts coming to a station or
YouTube channel near you all to tell its
horrific story of alien invasion but
what exactly that story is where it's
headed is what we're covering today
don't touch that dial we'll be right
back after this message from our
sponsors in case you haven't seen local
58 full slate of episodes even though I
did link to it and told you that it's
only 20 minutes long but I get it
sometimes you don't want to do that sort
of thing sometimes you just want me to
tell you everything you need to know for
the theory so here you go here's a real
brief rundown of the seven episodes
they've released in the order that they
were published which doesn't appear to
be the order in which the videos are set
in but we're gonna get to that the first
video is called you are on the fastest
available route and is simply some
dashcam footage of someone driving
through a storm at night it is super
normal until the GPS system starts
telling the driver to go off on
abandoned roads and turn off his
headlights then in 308 turn off your
headlights we see a flash whoever is
behind the camera runs and the camera is
knocked to the ground Blair Witch style
it's followed by contingency which
appears to be a government announcement
from the 1960s telling viewers that the
United States has been defeated by a
foreign country in it we see a series of
instructions about how Americans should
off themselves to preserve the dignity
of the country with the ominous phrase
that this message will repeat until
there are none left to read it the video
ends with the local 58 station making a
correction that the message was a hoax
but um it's a little late for that one
let's hope people weren't too quick on
the trigger there literally video three
Weather Service it starts as an ordinary
local weather alert which is already
scary enough because of those really
traumatic siren
but this isn't any snow watcher flood
warning that you're used to this is
about a meteorological event that makes
it unsafe for people to go outside and
look at the sky there's a correction
shortly after that though that tells
viewers that the event is indeed safe
for all to view and that the warning has
been lifted followed by instructions to
go outside now the video goes back and
forth on whether we are or aren't safe
before we end with a shot of the moon
coming into frame and people screaming
in the background
it's here yet the fourth video station
ID is largely the same with a few new
messages like look away it does not
matter there are other receivers safety
in numbers
it also tells us that the frequency of
the channel is 476 megahertz judging by
me pointing this little detail out you
might rightly assume that this will
become important later on moving on to a
show for children this one's all about a
cartoon skeleton wandering through a
graveyard at night so pretty standard
children's programming for 4:15 in the
morning the skeleton lies down in his
own grave and dies when the moon passes
over him you might be sensing a pattern
here video number 6 is called a look
back and it initially appears to be just
a recap of programming on the channel
before it gets interrupted by more
messages that say we send signals to
ourselves through their domain did we
really believe they wouldn't add their
own and lastly the most recent video is
called real sleep and it's probably the
weirdest of the bunch it initially looks
like an instructional video about how to
get the best sleep possible but true to
form things start getting weird when it
goes through an exercise that attempts
to erase the concept of facial
recognition from the viewer then
bombarding them with subliminal messages
like this is your time now there is work
to be done we are our own gods you owe
the messenger and that's the channel my
friends so what on earth does all this
mean obviously we got ourselves themes
about sleep the moon and messages coming
from outside of local 58's broadcasts
that makes the conclusion that we're
seeing something to have to do with
aliens a pretty easy one to deduce but
it also leaves us with three main
questions one what are those alien
doing through local 58 - what do they
want and three why are they interfering
with local broadcast networks when they
could very easily just be watching
syndicated early-2000s episodes of
Frasier let's start first with what we
believe the aliens are actually doing
which is hijacking the radio signals
through local 58's airwaves
interestingly hijacking radio signals
for Public Television is a thing that's
happened throughout history though not
by aliens
at least that we know of one of the most
famous examples is the Max Headroom
incident from 1987 a local TV station in
Chicago was playing an episode of Doctor
Who when the transmission was
interrupted by a strange rambling figure
in a rubber mask of 1980s cartoon
personality Max Headroom this goes on
for nearly two minutes during which time
he spouts advertising slogans references
Michael Jackson and gets spanked by a
flyswatter
well the Max Headroom incident wasn't
the work of aliens the FCC never did
catch the culprit and it's an example of
how someone can hack into local TV
signals even with low tech equipment
station ID indicates that the frequency
of local 58 is 476 megahertz
and interestingly enough we have indeed
detected unidentified radio signals from
space of similar frequency radio
telescopes in British Columbia have
picked up numerous fast radio bursts or
FRBS from as far as light-years away and
at frequencies as low as 400 megahertz
signals that scientists can't really
explain the origins of this kind of
mysterious radio burst would lead us to
believe that extraterrestrial invaders
could use similar frequencies to
intercept television broadcasts and in
the local 58 universe aliens are using
those radio waves to send messages
directly to us viewers either
subversively through programming like a
cartoon for children teaching kids to
lay down and look at the moon like the
cute cartoon skeleton and sometimes in
much more direct ways like telling us to
just look at the sky in weather service
this is all confirmed by that brief
message in a look back we send signals
to ourselves through their domain seems
to be talking about humans use of
antennas and satellites up in space the
Veii is presumably some kind of
extraterrestrial their domain a space
and then the message continues did we
really believe they wouldn't
their own calling out that the signals
are coming back to earth having been
altered tampered with by the aliens with
their own agenda in short there are
multiple voices coming at us through the
local 58 broadcasts one coming from the
aliens and one coming from someone else
either a scientist or someone working at
the station who knows what's going on we
see them fighting for control of the
screen and Weather Service first we're
told to remain indoors do not look at
the sky but is then followed seconds
later with the meteorological event to
see for all to view warning has been
lifted but that all brings us to
question number 2 what do these aliens
want I mean the goal is clearly for us
to look at the moon as demonstrated by
the cartoon and the weather report but
why in this case it seems like the
series still has some unanswered
questions but we're clearly dealing with
some kind of lunar bird box situation
where as soon as you look at the moon
you die or you go crazy well the
mechanics of the actual moon kill are
unclear it seems like they're exerting
an influence by hijacking people's
willingness to follow instructions that
they hear on the news it's counting on
the fact that we as humans believe what
we're told on television and we'll
follow it without question there's no
bolder example of this than the
instructions that are found in
contingency this is by far the most
chilling video of the series which
appears to play an emergency broadcast
segment that was supposed to have been
destroyed back in the 1970s it looks
like a message that's related to the
Cold War an era in which nuclear
tensions were high the threat of death
from above was more real than it ever
had been in America's history and the
anti-communist block propaganda was
everywhere in other words it was a time
in which Americans were feeling
pressured to be patriotic and to fear
the dangers that were coming from
outside their borders contingency looks
like it was probably the first
transmission that the aliens sent via
local 58 based both on the date by which
the message is supposed to be destroyed
and in the overall video quality now
what happened after that since not
everybody immediately followed the
instructions on the television to off
themselves the aliens then resorted to
messaging that they would hope would get
people to kill each other rather than
themselves and their families
and that's where real sleep comes in a
video that we see is from 1983 while
real sleep starts like a normal
or at least acceptable weird
instructional video that seems like it
wants to help people have restful sleep
the message is quickly corrupted by the
odd inclusion of distorted faces and
subliminal messages
some of them seem like they're
encouraging violence as I mentioned
before whereas others sound like they're
against the idea of sleep itself
including sleep is not civilized the
pure of mind do not slumber and when we
sleep we die so why exactly what the
aliens care about people's ability to
recognize faces or sleep quality
I mean I'm up late writing these scripts
a lot of times but you don't see me
running with open arms to my lunar
overlords unless by lunar overlord you
mean Wendy's late-night snack menu no
it's not to make people docile or sleepy
it's to make them hate each other
psychology studies show that a failure
to subliminally recognize pain and other
people's faces and sleep deprivation
both lead to a decrease in empathy for
other humans if real sleep is trying to
plant messages in people's minds about
the work to be done and then also blunts
viewers recognition of faces and
conditions them to not sleep all of it
is pointing to a concerted mind
controlling effort that hopes to get
humans to kill each other all the videos
from messing with GPS signals to messing
with people's understanding of faces and
sleep to children's programming and
weather alerts and even to quote unquote
governmental warnings all of it is
pointing to one concerted goal for the
aliens wipe us out by using our signals
to trick us into offing ourselves but
why I mean yes we're sending broadcasts
through their domain but that basically
just amounts to a cosmic noise complaint
why jump to kill us all off well think
about the initial timing of the alien
transmissions
we can't pinpoint exactly when
contingency aired but it's safe to
assume that it was in or before 1970
since it says the message is not for use
after 1113 1970 we already talked about
the fact that this was during the Cold
War but what I didn't specifically
mention about that time period was that
it was also the pinnacle of the space
race like the Cold War the space race
was also a battle between the US and the
USSR but this time it was for cosmic
supremacy or at least lunar supremacy
and it featured the first ever moon
landing by the Apollo 11 team in nine
in 69 now I'm clearly a theorist but it
seems like local 58 may be playing off
of some of the conspiracy theories that
exists around this massive scientific
achievement specifically the theory that
the Apollo 11 crew saw aliens when they
were visiting the moon as the theory
goes after the lunar module landed with
Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin inside
there were a few minutes of silence
between them and Mission Control back in
Houston this is just a true fact of what
happened that day but some people claim
that in the period of silence you can
hear a discussion between Aldrin and
Armstrong on their private medical
channels about extraterrestrial objects
as a result they rush to complete their
mission
planting research mirrors on the moon
and then quickly hightail it out of
there
whether these in my opinion highly
unlikely conspiracy theories are true
isn't the point here the point is that
the timing works out for this event the
moon landing to be the basis for local
58's aliens and their motivation to want
to kill us
we've made contact and we've made them
mad and what's not up for debate is that
Apollo 11 really did put mirrors on the
surface of the Moon as part of a way to
track the moon's orbit using lasers back
on earth and it just so happens that a
few of the strange messages from local
58 broadcasts do indeed mention mirrors
Weather Service explicitly warns people
to avoid mirrors and later says he found
me through the mirror moon alien
conspirators also believed that the
reason the space program ended as
quickly as it did and the reason that
the Apollo 11 astronauts weren't more
celebratory when they returned earth was
because they saw disturbing
disheartening things up in space and
couldn't tell the public and we know for
a fact that someone working at local 58
knows what's really going on here and is
trying to get the message out but just
can't which would seem to line up with
that regardless it certainly seems that
the space program is responsible for the
animosity that these aliens have for
life on Earth maybe the aliens want
revenge for being disturbed maybe the
movie first man is true and Neil
Armstrong is just really kind of a
bummer to hang out with we just don't
have enough of this story right now to
know the truth but we do have one last
hint about where the story might go and
that's in the first published video
which also happens to be the most recent
from a timeline perspective you are on
the
fastest available rounds if you look
closely for a brief moment the video
actually shows us one of the
extraterrestrial creatures and the
person who encounters it doesn't seem to
have survived so after trying to make
mankind destroy itself for decades maybe
the aliens have decided to take matters
into their own hands
we'll just have to wait for the next
broadcast of local 58 to be sure but hey
that's just a theory Oh
film theory and the truth is out there
you